If I hadn't thought I'd become a woman, I'd
live in a run-down apartment with thin walls
, and I'd end my life
.
4 minutes
[Applause]
Pooh
me,
it was when I was wet I'm a
junior high school student
.
Naoto Tachibana
That's right
12 years later this guy will die
12 years later on July 1st
Your sister will
die at
that time I'll tell
you that you'll die together
July 1st 2017
Remember this day Naoto
So  Please protect my sister, I understand
[Applause]
Please help me.
You helped my
sister
.
In other words, my sister won't get involved in the conflict
and die.I was scared if I could go back to my junior high school days and stop the two of them from meeting.
That might have been the trigger
Handshaking Gon
I was saved by you at that time
It
might be that I became a part of your ability
I thought, but
Naoto believes that I can time leap, so it's
so big I
swear
Kenbi, are you ready?
People did it 12 years ago in August
Please contact one of them and act together to stop the encounter I
'll try to do something about
it
I can go back to the future as long as I have the sound and the volume I can't
save what I did
to you
[Music]
Why do boys
always
fight?
And Hina will protect you
I've been doing it from now on, so if it's a boy, I'll be strong
ah ah ah
season Then
I'll protect Hina too I
came back
I called you Hino
It's better
[music] Yeah [music]
But it's the chicks who will protect
them, huh.
I don't want to forget the money I didn't
forget about
it
Manjutsu see you tomorrow aah
ana
[music]
[applause]
12 years later
Me and Hina haven't dated and
haven't seen each other in years
[music]
I don't have any obligation to save Hina
I'll protect you Hanagashi
But that
guy
[music]
5 is a believer Start haha
Kiyomasa-senpai
[music]
Buy Taiman
wh
[music]
Nothing if it doesn't flow  I can't go home
,
Noah, don't
run away
.
[Applause]
earena Quit
now
Oh, oh, oh
the van
me
yeah
me n
specifications masa yana yeah yeah yeah
re re re re
ah ah ah ah
I'm ashamed of my heart.  Yeah,
oh, oh, oh,
gene, it's the reason
Tokyo man next time,
Shio masa
You've got to kill me, I'm
definitely losing,
I'll save Hina Bring me a
bag
I'll do this,
auntie La Thaiman-
chan
!
President
Preferential hourly wage
Grain shot racke
Manners are completely cured
Don't call that nickname in a place like this I've
lost dorayaki What the hell
is that guy I
can't read the atmosphere at all
Thank you for your hard work here I don't
know
Please
Zan come on me Akko guy is not in Tokyo next time
Top man zero
[Music]
Last time I was doing it somewhere in Thailand
Red index
Well, I'm not interested in the role, I
'm sorry for the year I'm
talking
.  Music]
Thank you for your hard work,
Bach,
Kiyomasa, I've become so great since Chu
.  That's why I guess that's right
only 3rd grade eh
ummm really junior high school
only road
starting today
you're the one in this car
tar
p
I'm going to imitate Mann's name, akemi Che See you later, let's break up
[music]
He's Toman's
Boz Sano
Manpaku ge Great one Cavity
I was moved Eh
Frog enemy's previous article
I do
n't know what you're thinking because you're Masa-kun. Did you
just change your job to a monster toy? It's even
more hell.
Introductory You said that with the front key of the inch, so that's
right Takemichi Kobe
Ah, it's cute, isn't it?
I tried to stab you.
Thank you martial arts
Thanks to you sticking out,
we were freed from slavery
It was cool
, you're
embarrassed Tan
Magi Shin  It was a
coincidence, but in
order to save Hina who was caught and died, I had to stop planning the next Tokyo Man.For
that reason, I made Toman's two tops not meet in the past and now,
one of them,
Manjiro Sano.  I managed to meet a
[music]
I don't know what to do
after this
Let's fly Takemichiho one way no 10 [ __ ]
this guy
, everyone in fame
What is this?
It
's going to be held
next time in Tokyo Man
After all, the team in Udagawa, who is going, is making a difference with Shin-san
.
I mentioned that it's about washing
, oh
Seed's room 4 I'm free today,
no, not
really.  I only remember the
pitiful Takeharu Mika Wasn't it decided by Ike-kun?
You have to yell and tie up
again Even if there's so much, this is just chatter store
If you can stop the meeting with Mikey,
let's go, wait a minute The
road
is
nice Oh  I'm sorry I'm so busy today tee
ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
let's go
takemitsu you can't do what these people say
hina will protect
you  Goodbye
, don't be silly Horror,
which one are you kidding?
You don't want to go to another school and force yourself to be taken away.
That's not what friends do.
Recently, the bamboo shoots are just getting dirty.
If it's your fault,
I won't forgive you.
I can't hear you,
eh,
Hina will protect you.
Hm, there's something I can't give up on,
I'll think twice
[music]
Ah, I thought I could stand up, but the mountain
Sasa How do you lay it down
?
] I don't
know this [music] 4 Huh, you're an idiot
Takimichi
You can't
mess with a woman huh dqn Sanchu
I'm so sorry for my partner
It's the
Showa era
[music] I
've been
biting,
I'm on the road, those people
It's a villainous group of
ants Cultural gambling and stuff
like that I can't get my hands on this much isn't it?
Excuse me for asking.
That's
terrible
[music]
Now it
's a situation where you're told to bring out a delinquent, right?
Back in the olden days, there were a lot of motorcycle
gangs around here, running around with straight-line calls.
I wiped it myself
Why are those guys in the batting line
?
It's okay to be a smooth guy, but
hey, if it's for the sake of something I can't compromise on, I'll stand up to any
guy like
you.
Scraft more Like crashing into a festival with a truck and killing unrelated chicks
Tokyo swastika change 12 years later
I'm definitely not the boss of that kind of organization I wonder what changed Mikey
[music]
Manjiro Sano Tokisaki  If the
two of us hadn't met,
there wouldn't have been the next episode of Tokyo Man now.